Ben babamdan başlayıp o kadar giden
eğitim sizle paylaşmak istiyorum Çünkü o
de bundan hattı özle
Bu Google'a tarafından özel bir
göremiyorum gördüm
bu Burada gider şeyler bir Söylemesi
kolay kabullendi zor ama o derecede
buluyoruz altıya o
dur dur dur Adam birazdan işte geldi
Nihat abi sen bulduğun mezunuyum musunuz
[Müzik]
böyle konuşmadan sonra ara sizin
babamdan başlayan spor dersini
[Müzik]
yıllarında Türkiye'de de en önemlisi de
ve dayanışma şerefine düşmüş 21 yaşında
genç bir futbolcu Allah'ın zamanda hukuk
fakültesi öğrencisi siz
yok babam
O benim kullandığım daha da senin siyah
gözlerin arkasında da sağlayan sert
bakışlarını ve bize olan ihtiyacını o
Gözlüklerin Arkasından da
[Müzik]
o gözlerini Adana'nın güneşinden korumak
için değil kalbin insanları izle izlemek
Çünkü dizisi gerekiyor bizlere
bildiklerini örebilirsiniz gerekiyor
hayatta her şey konusunda öğrendiğinde
her şeyi
mi Elif davranış
abone ol
eğer birgün akşam çocukluğumdaki bir
kadın adamı yanında ne yaptınız bir
seyahatin görüşürük
Hoş geldiniz babam Buralar bölgedeki de
önemli
o pornosunu üst düzeye size ve senin
e Devlet kendisine
bu maruz dediğimiz Ağaçören taktığımız
bu dönemin Song of
ve yaşlı olan bir arabasını bir
ayrıyeten otomobil gibi makam arabası
olarak
İyi aferin
bu ara o gece
da aynı olarak
Bu izlerden dönemimizde aile olarak
yazın yanında gözler
İyi tamam gel
o mavi interaktif telefonlara kadar
döneceğiz bekleyen fark onlarda sürün
yüklerinizi Valizleri tutarak
bu Emin Efendi ödemek mavi üzerinde
Çünkü resmi hizmete mahsustur duruyordu
bu izle Akif birisinde resmi göre değil
ve ayrıca aslında
bu dolar nasıl Oğlum bana öreceğiz
bu olmalı insanları Tamam ikinci
yarısında nasıl kullanılması gerekir biz
O senin gözün uzaya dersiniz zaman
Bu ürünler çalışmaz çalışkan ol
ya ondan sonra olması için sizin nasıl
sorusunu görmesi lazım çocuğunuza Siz
yalan söylemedim ki
O sizin çocuğunuza doğruyu söylememiz
doğru söyledin mi
bu BİM
Fiat Doğan olan bütün bu hafta alırım
bütün bilincinde Bu aile başlayınca
Bu çocukların güzel filmler dolaşıyor bu
sene oldu
bu neler olacak
o Çünkü 1997-98 sezonunda basketbol
takımı Türkiye basketbol liginden
basketbol Süper Ligi'nde çıkma Savaşı
veriyordu o o
[Müzik]
Az önce doğradığımız Arda daha önce an
niteliğinde kapandım Yanlış olan
kimselerden kuşum
Sağ ol oğlum haliderede
o benim arkadaşım olarak görünsün yani
daha önceden Baba antrenör çocuk o
oyuncu senaryosunu çalışıyor zaten
o deniz fotoğrafları
Bu vatanı
ben seni
da yüzüklerimiz
O bizim bütün hayatınızla ilgili olarak
söylenmesi kolay ama biz zor olayları
önünde gördüm
doğum günü
Bu benim hayatım olduğu kadar ellerinde
fazla açın hayatında uzun Yapı yaşam
Usta izin birçok şeyi farklı yaptığımızı
oldu
abone ol
ya Ozan olsun o
ve 60'lı yılların son dönemleri doğmuş
mavi yapacak söndü
38 80 doğumlu zarı çaylar beş
bu ve
o geri kalan
16 tane 70'lerde doğmuş nasıl üretim
oluşturan burada ne vardı söylüyordu
bu Ama ortada
ama her şey bir arkadaşı karış acıların
ortaya çıkmasıyla hepimize söylemesin
kolay olan kabul edilmesi zor kampına
girdi abisi
bu Burdur bölgesi ikincisi malzeme
düşmüş su üçüncüde Benim başım o
bu göre zor arkadaş
en uygun bakış açısına baktığımızda ise
ya ortadaki kesin vardı birisi güzel
ailesi ve
Allah Allah ulaşım zorluğu iyi bilmesi
imkansız çünkü sağda da o sahibi
bildiğimiz anıları olmayacak artık o
genç yaşında O da
ve o ana kadar elde ettiği başarılar
İlkokulu Sitesi ve Türkiye
standartlarının üzerinde ki
bu birinci kapasitesi belirleri şeylerin
verdi
O da hadi geliyorsun daha iyi olur ya
ben sana da
Ben babamdan aldım içinde bu yuvamda
öğrencileriyle
Ben hayatımda böyle yapıyorlar
bu ama böyle Sokaklar
bu hoş sır vereceğim size o takımın iyi
göğsü
Bu doğrultuda elin kapasitesini
geliştirmeye hazır Çünkü İngilizce'de
çalışacağım etme yeteneğini götürürsün
kazanmış mi
Bu problem omuzda buradayız önümüze
arkadaş arkadaşları ve almıyor mu
mi ben mi
abone ol
hoş geldin
o çünkü Eğer siz
ve herhangi bir hata olduğunda
Bu odanın doğrusunun Ne oldu mesajın
vermek için
Ne oldu kullanırız Örneğin
3194 askere karşı çıkartırken ne topu
kaybettiğinde alıyorsun diye bağırır
ya Bodrum göreği Eğer gelince konuşuruz
ve Arkadaşları bütün algılar da
ve bağırsaklarda gözlüğünü yani boşta
Oğlum neden olacak artık ya sorgulamaya
başlarlar mercanda Taylan yapmadım ki
abone ol
bu problemler
O öyle daha yenilgi Allah
o gerçeklerin önerilir
abone ol
Bu neden böyle bugün bu konuşma yaptım
Yani neden oluyor Neden ekonomik neden
askeri harekatlar daha önemli değil
Evet şu anda kuşağında şeyler deyince
herhalde yaşadığım ve karşılaştığım Eğer
onlardan bugün yani o
abone ol
bu sonra
ben Sinan
o bizden mezun olup üniversiteye
başlayacağız sıralarda
ve hermes'in yaşadığınızı evde de
Türkiye'deki itin ve spor sattığını daha
iyi değerlendirerek ki
Bu İstanbul'da daha iyi bir üniversite
kazanırsın olması beraber yeni serisinde
kazıyarak
bu olmayabiliriz
yok bende
bu dilerim
o resmi şekilde sınavında da Onur zor
durumda bırakacak ve ondan sonra
bırakacak herhangi bir kararda bulunmaya
çalışıyoruz Ondan sonra da
bu üstü olabileceği zamirler
olabileceğim veya patronları
olabileceğim Yorganda bir pozisyonda
çalışmak durumunda
Yok kurbanım
ve Suriye var mı istiyor
Ben bugün onlar da düzgün yetişkin var
O ne haber sonsuz çok iyi çalışıyoruz
bu tür çalışmalarımızın
bu ne zaman noktasında
3'ünün acil patlatmalar
abone ol
var burada da olayı bağlamak istediğim
o p****
o ölümcül 7 eğitim konusu espor konusu
Maalesef benim çok ciddiyim
Emeğe saygı duyuyorum
bu ve üzüldüm şu anda sahnede
gördüğünüzde ekranda gördüğünüz şarj
Türkiye'deki
bu sporun güzel kabarmış soru sorun
de içinde bulunduğum kalmış ilgili
yaparken çocuklarımız isteseydim
eğitimlerini sporlarını istediğimiz en
güzel şekilde o
bu işe girmiş şişle sporun eğitimle Jin
düğününe geçirdiği görünümünü
görevlerini ve sorumluluklarını yok
ettiği Evet arkadaşlar
bu başlarımız
bu basketbolda böyle bir güzel oluyor
Bunu diğer sporlarda da düşünebiliriz
ancak
de iyiyim burada hepimize
ki bunda ilgili spora taşınması değil
Sorun artık evimize yazısı ve eğitimi ve
sporun her zaman için daha da daha basit
bir şekilde bir arada Aynı Çatı Altında
aynı felsefeyle aynı düzeldi için o
Sen beni dinlediğiniz için Çok teşekkür
ederim O